i'm very happy that we're starting uh
this new experiment uh with expert
briefings prior to the pi data global
conference and thank you thomas for uh
being the first uh in the five that we
are running this week and so thomas has
been a long time open source member uh
one of the core developers on the pi
mcps imc3
probably yeah i can't speak now
probabilistic programming
framework uh which alongside stan is one
of the two most popular uh they're kind
on the planet
thomas is going to going to give us a
state of the art for probabilistic
programming
in general and then open the floor to
questions and so thomas uh is well known
in the pi data world uh and then the
wider academic world so uh thomas over
to you we're recording this call we can
go on for an hour um or less as needs be
um thomas please take the floor
well thank you so much thanks everybody
for joining i'm very excited to be here
and
talk about my favorite topic uh
probabilistic programming and pi and c
um
i just have a couple of slides really
the idea of this format is that it's
interactive so
there will be maybe 10 15 minutes of
slides where i think
where we are today and where we're
headed and then open the floor to
questions and discussions
so uh yeah really looking forward to
that and hearing from you so
i'm thomas i'm
most recently the ceo and founder of
pimezylabs our amazing
bayesian consultancy
we basically just help customers
build and solve the most advanced data
science problems they have
using
basic modeling and probabilistic
programming
and i couldn't be more proud of the team
that we have assembled there's actually
quite a couple of more people now than
that are listed here but
we all
come from the prime c quad developer
team so with inventors of prime c
and
between us we have decades of experience
in this type of base and modeling right
we wrote it and we just love using it so
it was very natural to
um
basically jump in and start this
consultancy
we work with clients from startups to
fortune 500 companies
and have team of diverse backgrounds
so probably most of you will be familiar
but maybe some of you are still like
well what is this phase in probabilistic
programming thing i keep hearing about
so i just want to give like a very very
high level overview of what i think
really is
uh the
uh the main reason for
why you should be interested in this
and what sets it apart really from other
approaches because i think it is very
unique
and gives you a lot of power and freedom
so
very high level for me the reason to use
it is because it gives me great
flexibility
and allows me to really express
my creativity in solving these problems
and is really empowerment empowering and
i think you'll find that when you start
using it that you just become a
different view of the world basically
and what you can and the type of
problems that you can solve
and i'd like to illustrate this with
this small comparison here where we have
playmobil
so in germany when you grew up there
were playmobil kids and they were lego
kids
and
[Music]
basically
um
playmobil is do you get a prepackaged
toy right here's the ambulance and you
can only play with it in the way that it
was designed to do right you can't turn
this into a rocket ship uh it's a
narrative and that's the only thing you
can do with it
and
but i mean it's nice right so it is like
very shiny and pre-packaged you don't
have to do anything to get it out of the
box and immediately can't start playing
so that's cool right but it's not as
flexible
and this is what i would label
more traditional frequency statistics
and most machine learning approaches
where
you have the pre-specified algorithm
right and it does what it's doing and
you can't really change it
now contrast that with lego right which
i mean nowadays the two have become more
similar but back in the day really all
you've got was just a whole bunch of
individual parts right and from that you
could build a particular toy but you
could all build all kinds of other
things
and
i always thought that this uh freedom
was really empowering right so if i
wanted an ambulance i could build an
ambulance but if i wanted a rocket ship
i could use those parts and some other
parts to build that rocket ship and um
yeah so that i think is really
empowering
and how i like to think of basin
modeling because it really is giving you
those basic building blocks in terms of
probability distributions
and allows you to assemble them in all
kinds of different ways in order to
solve
not every prediction problem out there
but the very particular problem that you
have in your data science task
and the other really cool thing about it
is
what i like to call the democratization
of statistics where back in the day you
really needed a whole lot of math right
if you wanted to build your own model
you had to derive say your own
estimators right
um you couldn't just say like oh that's
the model i want let me just like fit it
but with probabilistic programming we
actually can express our models in
computer code and with pipe c you can do
that in python
and that is part of that um what makes
it so powerful for me is not only can i
build these flexible models um and
but i can also
assemble them in a few lines of python
code and then
finally
the fitting of that is actually
automatic um
so to summarize the the idea
we have data and then we have a custom
base and model we don't have a black box
um we don't have a t-test and then the
output of that are probabilities so we
can reason about things in a
probabilistic sense
meaning we can quantify on uncertainty
in our risk that we're taking on
so as i said we can tailor model to a
specific problem
um we can also incorporate expert domain
knowledge right anything we know about
the structure of the problem ahead of
time or maybe about certain parameters
that we think are going to be in a
certain domain
we can incorporate that and that in the
business setting is also incredibly
powerful because it allows you to
talk to your stakeholders right and
let's say with a black box machine
algorithm essentially what you have to
do is come in and say well maybe
people in this company already have
decades of experience solving this
problem
we're just going to throw all of that
out the window and we're going to just
[Music]
train a classifier on data and that's
all there is to it right and that's
going to replace everything
here we can actually talk to these
people and say okay well what what have
you learned what is the insight and
incorporate that to the model and get
the best of both worlds in this way
and that usually goes way better if
integrating this um and of course
coupled with the transparency
and as i said
uh prostate programming allows you to do
that in computer code and fit those
models automatically so that's leads to
really fast erasing cycle and building
custom solutions quickly
so i would go on the record and say
i think it's the easiest and most
powerful framework for statistical
modeling currently out there
okay so that's basically the intro
um
i'm gonna skip this here
um
but now you might be wondering well if
it's so amazing
um why is not everyone using it
that's a good question um i mean the
main reason is i still think it's not as
well known as it should be so i think
more people should be using it because
you can use it today to solve
really tricky um
industry scale problems and we do right
that's that's um
thousands of people um
[Music]
thousands of papers subsided by and see
many many companies are using it
and it's not a toy right it is an
industry scale application tool but i
still think that there is a lot to be
desired and that's
what i'd like to talk about next
and
one of the key things that we keep
hearing is that probabilistic
programming is slow
and
that is
true
um
to a certain extent it's a little bit
more nuanced so
um first of all it used to be much truer
than it is today
so
we used to be able
so these early systems they didn't
really scale well in terms of the model
complexity right so you could build
a regression model right and then
automatically fit that
things like wind bugs or jags
um
you couldn't really
use a lot of data or very complicated
models these days
i would say we scale to like
medium sized
complexity in terms of model and
medium-sized data sets
more concretely what i mean with that is
we have fit models with
40 to 50 000 parameters
in under half an hour
at quantocon for example
and we have also
ran it on models with um
[Music]
a million data points
um and that works right um so it scales
that far uh which is not nothing right
you can solve all kinds of problems with
that and especially a lot of times
business modeling is being used in the
domain where you don't have as much data
right that's where things like priors
and expert knowledge become more
relevant because if you don't have a lot
of information you need to get the
information from other sources
but if you do well of course you might
still want to use bayes and models and
more complicated models
um but yeah currently
the scaling beyond that is still
an issue and i mean certainly there's
many data sets with more than a million
rows and
models where you want to fit more than
100 000 parameters so i think that is
really the future
and i think there's a really good story
for it where well if you have that much
data
the
model that you can't fit
is also going to be
can is allowed to be much more complex
than not right if you have more
information
you can infer more patterns from the
data and you can include those into your
model so with big data you can build
more complex models
but currently
the tooling is still not quite there
but that's what we're about to change
yeah so this is what i said we can scale
especially the
nuts algorithm or hamiltonian monte
carlo is what essentially allowed the
second generation so the first
generation i would call wind bugs and
jags second generation stan and prime c3
which have adopted these gradient-based
samplers nuts and hamiltonian mother
color to make it scale to this medium
size
and
um
[Music]
so but i think we need to eventually do
this third
third um
domain
uh but the other take also is and we see
this all the time so uh customers come
to us and they say like oh our model
takes six to seven hours to run can you
help us and we usually get it down to 30
sometimes even less than 10 minutes
but only part of that is really
working on the core speed of the model a
lot of times
when you have a computation problems
there's a really often a problem with
your model so that's the first thing
that should be addressed and that is
where we get
insane speedups
just because the sampler is working much
better if you have
a model that's easy to sample from
so this is known as the fork theorist
it's still computing
expressed by gallo and we yeah like this
couldn't be more true like almost every
model that we work with we find
some issues that we fix
and then the whole thing just works much
better there are no divergences sampling
is fast
um but it's actually quite difficult so
that is why people come to us is because
they can solve that on their own
and
this is what i personally started
calling the dark arts of bayesian
modeling
which are
model reparametizations
and
this is an advanced topic where
essentially if you write a model right
let's say it's a hierarchical model
there's not just a single way to write
this model there are
at least two ways often there are many
more ways
and
even though the model is conceptually
the same
the two models just on a different
parametrization sample completely
different
so they can be much faster um sampling
or have fewer differences by just
applying a simple mathematical
formulation
and
what's even more difficult is that it's
not really clear which parameterization
even is available right so if it's a
hierarchical there's none centered and a
centered parameterization first of all
you have to know about that
there are many other ones which you have
to know about right there's no um real
cookbook on this that process is not
automated
and it's also not clear which one is the
best
sometimes the center primarization is
best sometimes not centered
prioritization at best
it does not only depend on the data also
depends on the uh not not does not only
depend on the model but also depends on
the data so it's even trickier so yeah
this is um
quite challenging and and something
where you need expert experts like us um
to do that but ultimately i mean we do
want to make that more automatic
so prime c
4.0
is going to be the future and address um
most of those all of those problems um
or at least lay the groundwork to really
solving those problems
a little bit of history because we did
quite a few renames um to clear this up
so pi mc3 has is the software that has
always been around and it was based on
theano
which is the core
graph computation library that allows
you to express
computations as graph representation and
then compile those to c then
so thiano was the predecessor of
pytorch and tensorflow and all these
other packages
and then they discontinued
then we
started to experiment with a prototype
called pmc4 which was based on
tensorflow a sensor for probability
but pretty quickly we abandoned this
because we found that tensorflow was not
the right fit
and thiano actually was
pretty much perfect for what we wanted
to do with it so what we did was fork it
to
something which is now called thiano
pymc
and the current version of pi mg3 rests
on our own forked fiona version
and while forking it and fixing some
issues with the copay we found that
actually thano is an amazing library
it just was a little bit stuck in the
past and a bit crusty so we went in and
fixed many issues there
and
renamed the library by rewriting it to
isara so this is the new library
the
entheano is the predecessor
so there's a extension of that but it's
actually quite a substantial rewrite in
many ways
and
pi and c 4.0 so we're renaming pi and c3
back to pi and c right and then we just
use consecutive version numbers so there
won't be a pi mc4 or pi c5 that will be
prime c 4.0 ymc 4.1 right and just like
like the same person would do it right
so we're going back to
to that
um
and that will be based on our sara and
the beta is going to come out in i think
uh maybe two weeks
so we're very very close
and what's exciting about is that well
there are many cool new features in it
but uh the two main ones that are most
visible are new computation backends so
you can not only compile to c but you
can also compile to number
which is an llbm compiler by anaconda
and that gives
it's really nice speed up in some
scenarios not at all
and still something that we're actively
working on and also jacks and for
anything that has like last large matrix
multiplications jax is actually really
powerful
and if there's other
libraries we can also target those quite
easily so uh sara is basically this
middle layer
which does the graph representation and
that can compile to different
back ends that are then fast
so what's new here well we try address
all these issues that i just mentioned
that are holding probability programming
back so we get better scalability due to
the jacks and number support
and through jax for example we also get
gpu support natively right and tpu
support even
and in like some early experiments we've
seen 10x speedups on allergic regression
model using this
sometimes we've seen even higher
speedups
so this
allows us to really
put more
oomph
behind the raw sampling
another thing which we started doing is
before our samplers were written in
python and only the model block
probability was written in
basically
theano or zara and was then compiled so
the python sampler was calling into the
c
speed run model probability
so of course that's still slow right
there's the overhead that you eat and
there's certain optimizations you can't
do
so now that we write the samplers in our
server themselves the whole model is
basically its own computational graph
and we can do
interesting optimizations on that graph
level and then compile the sample and
the model
block probability to either jacks or
number in in the case of jacks for
example and if you want to run it on gpu
then the sampling and the
um
[Music]
and the model operability are running on
the gpu so it's just one program and you
set it off and that would get become
much much faster than just the 10x
speedup
so really excited about that
that one will take a little bit longer
and the other thing
what this allows us now to do is these
automatic referee writes
so there's some simple ones right so if
you just have the log of an x you can
simplify that to x that's going to be
more numerically stable and faster
so we can discover those easily now and
and optimize them away and there's more
and more that we're adding
but we can also do that more in a
statistical way
so if you have a normal distribution
centered on 0 and 1 and you multiply
that with a value and add a value
well you can rewrite that to just be
normal distribution center around mean a
standard deviation b
so
um
and again like sometimes this
parametrization will be better sometimes
it doesn't parameterization will be
better
and
we can automatically generate those so
that's also something um that basically
then allows you to automate this dark
art process by just encoding all these
parametrization that you can do
into our
rewriting engine and then we can just
generate different types of
parameterization for the model and the
user doesn't have to do that
and we can do much more like
marginalization if you have discrete
parameters these nice hamiltonian
samples do not work
so we can do that automatically
and then another big thing of course is
just better teaching so i think these
tools and concepts can be taught
much more
intuitively and efficiently and we're
now creating an online course intuitive
based modeling
that you can check out on our homepage
um
where which is going to be an online
course um that we where we teach you
how to use these tools most effectively
here's some references
um
yeah check out our
suite basing consultancy if you have
data science problems
my blog where i have all kinds of
blog posts on different tutorials on
various
pmc tricks
the website for pi and c
twitter or you can email me
and
yeah so with that i'd like to open up
the floor to questions discussions uh
here's some discussion points
um
so
uh maybe first we start with questions
but also if you'd have thoughts to share
on like what type of like what have your
experience has been i'm really curious
to hear
uh have you already used ppl's in
practice how's that been successful
what stumbling blocks did you encounter
while doing that and which project
programming language are you using and
why
so
um
there are
yeah so maybe we'll just open it up and
we'll
i don't know if you want to moderate ian
for sure uh so first of all thomas uh
thank you very much you're bang on time
um and that was a nice clear briefing so
thank you very much that's great um
everyone else uh it'll be good if you
could uh
say thank you to thomas by uh going to
the chat window and uh saying thanks or
something along those lines there um
or waving yeah exactly waving or saying
thanks in the chat window whichever one
works for you um that was very good um
and to ask questions um i would propose
either unmuting yourself and then
saying hey thomas and asking the
question or in the chat window um
making a clear question there and typing
it out so that thomas can filled it um
either is good i'm going to try and keep
out of the way of this um so uh either
speak out loud with your question or
type it into the chat window either is
good and i'll just step back thank you
thomas
thank you yeah thanks all for the
positive vibes i appreciate it
um
so
ppl stands for probably programming
language
that's
that's an easy one to field
but but yeah also feel free to unmute
yourself and
[Music]
uh share your own experiences so yeah
like who here has used probabilistic
programming
uh successfully and and
what has your experience been so there's
a question uh at the end of the chat
there for you thomas
okay
do you recommend do you recommend any
ways of introducing ppls and basic
statistics to the wider community
find that there's a steep learning curve
yes um
i think you're right on the money there
that is still
the biggest problem holding it back is
that
things like
uh
psychic loan right is amazing um
you just import a random forest
you run it and
then
it does something quite sensible most of
the time right these are very robust and
if you have a problem that fits into
that mold
it's gonna do the right thing and what's
cool is you don't even have to really
understand what the random force really
does right it will just most of the time
will just work
if you do understand it that's helpful
right then you know like oh about the
tree depth and
um and all kinds of other hyper
parameters that you might want to tune
um but really it's
it's it's pretty easy to get going with
that and get good results
probably programming you have to know
more you have to know
probability boostions you have to know
some core
of
conditional probability right and how it
all fits together then you have to have
just this practical experience of doing
it so um i've definitely been
guilty of this um
in overstating and maybe how simple it
is right i mean because i think yes you
can do very powerful things and
the probabilistic programming
makes that simpler but is it really easy
well not really right if you actually
then go down to sit
um and build your model
um you maybe are able to write it down
but then you're like well which prior
should i use like why how to find that
out
then you get divergences with like
really cryptic error messages what is
that about
so
yeah those are things that the course is
trying to
help you with like what type of priors
and just better documentation
um
but yeah i think there's a lot to be
done here um
and
um
i'm just talking about a question yeah
that um so yeah i think it's just um
the efforts that we are undertaking in
terms of making it more intuitive
because i think
um actually a lot of the teaching
materials are quite bad so um like one
of the bibles i guess right is
um
what is that most famous gelman book is
in data analysis bda
and
that starts out just very theoretical
right and it's not hands-on at all so if
that's the first book that you pick up
it's quite easy to be um frustrated and
i have had those frustrations and
learning it myself
where i found like oh man um
once i like finally got a concept i'm
like okay well this is actually quite
straightforward
um why hasn't anyone like explained this
to me in normal terms
and that's what we're doing with that
course and that's what i'm trying to do
in my blog and i think there is this
other way um to like ramp people up in
being much more hands-on and working
with it of course not by now they're
also much better books that's the theory
thinking is really good um
um there's a book for specifically
targeted on pine c most of these book
also like statistically thinking we have
ported to pi and c so you can read the
book and still use the prime c code
examples um with like um things on the
website
um so yeah that's what i would say um
there's a raised hand um i can't see the
name but you have your video on hi
thomas
hey
thank you for the talk
thank you and uh thank you for all your
efforts in pmc in general um i just
mentioned that
pimc is my go-to tool oh sorry so i
should mention i'm a
data scientist i've been doing analysis
for about over 15 years now um and pi
mc3 is my go-to tool
especially when i have to deal with
something um non um something that i
can't solve analytically
um and so i use it on on a professional
uh level not day to day but at the
random chance in which i need to solve
something um i can give like a concrete
example for example um so if you um so
just the simplest thing one can imagine
just better distributions let's say you
have a model um accuracy but you can't
sample all the data you have a small
sample so i deal with a small uh
small sample
statistics
and so
you know a better distribution
represents the accuracy of the model uh
but then you have more challenging
questions like well let's say i have two
models a and b
um
is one better than the other and all i
have is a small sample and i looked
online and i see there's no analytical
thing that i can just pen and paper
write it down and i'll correct me if i'm
wrong about that and so i figured well
bmc i can just write down the better
distributions of each and just sample
like differences between them and create
a metric and that's that's kind of like
how i solve for that um please correct
me if i'm there's analytic analytical
solution that i'm missing and i can do
it but otherwise i'm looking forward
towards uh your course by the way
i think you can learn how to use it more
effectively yeah
um and if you want to share
like what's the specific problem like
what's the domain
oh i work in healthcare
okay
and so i'm looking at
oh so i'm i work on a
feature called symptom checker you put
in your symptoms and it will tell you uh
what level of emergency should you deal
with it is it just go to the pharmacy or
god forbid go to the hospital
and
um
so
we have our ai give
you know what it thinks the truth is and
then i compare that versus what a
clinician says so we have various
metrics of accuracy one for example is
safety how safe is it meaning that if
the
clinician says the outcome should be um
you should speak to a gp within 24 hours
and the ai let's say uh says something
like oh this is something that you can
take care at home on your own then that
one would be considered not safe so i
want to quantify how safe is the product
and so
i have model a that has some accuracy
level and then i have model b that has a
different accuracy level but because the
ground truth is very expensive we have
to pay clinicians to go over what's
called a vignette and actually give the
ground truth i cannot sample all of my i
cannot annotate all my data but i have a
small sample and so that sample
represents the model at
large does that make sense yeah it
really does that's such an interesting
application for it
and uh why did you use
um imc and not uh like machine learning
not so i could learn or something like
that
oh because i i don't i don't need to um
use machine learning it's very
simplistic i just have you know two
columns of data i have the ground truth
and i have
um you know the ground truth from the
clinicians and then i have from the ai
and i'm just doing an analysis i'm not
doing like machine learning to update
our models i'm just um reporting as an
on that you know
reporting as an analyst like okay um the
performance of the model and i want to
know
again we're dealing with small sample
statistics like i want to know the
credibility of what the accuracy of the
model actually is and if i have two
models then that becomes um you know
more parameters and then i want to
compare between the two and i can't do
that analytically and so that's why um i
just chuck everything through pi and c3
and then i can do that minus sign
between the two samples and then i have
distribution of what the difference
would be between the two models
yeah so essentially it's a hypothesis
test between two different models that
you have right i should have started my
answer with that yes that would have
been much more clear hypothesis no no i
mean yeah uh yeah that's interesting i
mean that's definitely a totally
developed um application of of um time c
like um so one thing you could look at
is the best the best um
uh bayesian estimation supersedes the t
test
yes that's exactly
oh that's what you're using perfect yeah
i i i i'd hear by krishky's philosophies
yes yeah nice
um
that's another great book by the way um
and uh but yeah it sounds like
definitely the right type of tool in i
mean one thing definitely that shines
through is that you really uh need good
uncertainty quantification right so it's
um always interesting to hear about
these problems because like yeah we
basically by now broken it down to these
types of things that allow you to
identify whether your problem is well
suited for probabilistic programming
and
you mentioned a couple of those right
you have small data set size
so probably classified that you can get
off the ground so it's
it's not a simple prediction problem you
want to gain insight and certainly plays
a big role and it's about real-world
decision-making right so
um
and
and for me like that point is always a
little bit
uh funny because well if you're not
doing real-world decision-making why
even trying to solve that problem in the
first place
and
um
i mean i guess
like let's say amazon or something right
if you don't make the perfect um
recommendation it's not the end of the
world right the person maybe just
doesn't buy
as much but in this case right whether
someone like goes to the er on time or
not is like really critical so there you
want to be really
uh conscious of how sure am i in that
recommendation right and if you're
unsure maybe you want to have a second
system and go to an expert and say well
i don't know in this case
so yeah
that is one downside of
many of these backbox machine learning
algorithms is they can't convey what
they have learned and also how sure or
unsure they are in the answer right they
don't really have a way of saying i
don't know
yeah yeah that's an excellent point and
what you talked about the safety of the
patient but also from the practical side
of logistics like if i report that the
model doesn't perform as bad the model
you know the new model doesn't perform
as well as the first model
then that we require a lot of
prioritization of resources like
engineering efforts and more data
scientists so um i like your point about
decision real life decision making in
that sense
yeah
um
and another thing that you might want to
look into is modern comparison uh
probably you've already come across this
but um
what you said about like comparing two
types of models um they're like certain
scores that you can use
um
like uh leave one out cross validation
um is a concept that's also in basic
modeling
and we have those in rvs which is the
statistical library that accommodates
prime c so that's something to look into
um but yeah thank you so much for
sharing that that was really interesting
exactly the type of discussion that i
was hoping we could engage in here
so next i'm going to take a question
here from the chat by paulini
i have a question i always had the
feeling that the flexibility of using a
bayesian approach also comes with the
cost of the extra time needed to get
some good results extra time compared
with frequent test approaches
assuming this is true you have some
layman selling points to justify this
extra time with business stakeholders
and get their buy-in
yes
so
i wholeheartedly agree with the first
premise of the question that
the flexibility does come at a cost at
the cost of um
greater time to build the model
um
and i guess that point is
easier
demonstrated if we compare to machine
learning right because machine learning
as i said is like this super quick thing
you just import it you run it you get
results perfect um
but then of course if you have more
things that you want your model to do
like you have certain structures in your
data like hierarchical nested data
then barely becomes impossible right
first based basic modeling
you can do that but it takes much longer
to
build that model
um the other comparison that i like to
use is uh well now let's stick to the
lego one right i mean yeah you
building on rocket ship in lego bricks
takes more time
[Music]
so
but you get exactly the type of thing
so
that cost
um i don't think we'll get rid of
mainly because
it is in the nature of the approach so
if you want something hand tailored
right
um you have to tailor it there's just no
way around it
um and there have been like
ideas of like an all the statistician
right where you just have a model that's
just going to fit everything
and
those are there are some interesting
approaches there but i think it misses
the point where we want to use bayesian
modeling for those cases where we have
that knowledge and we want to fit a very
particular mode
and and that just takes time and
exploration
but that is not wasted time right
because not only do you get a better
model but also you learn something about
your problem so by building this model
it's really
um interesting process and i think you
really have to go through it in order to
fully appreciate it as a lot of the
assumptions that you had coming into
this you realize we're wrong right so
and you realize that through two ways
one is
for the first time you're really now
forced to write down exactly what you
think um
the structure in this data set is right
so for the first time you're like oh
well does this thing connect to this
thing and is there a hierarchy here and
what is the likelihood function so now
you're forced to
write that down
and that helps you to clarify your own
thinking and then well once it's written
down you can communicate that to other
people
so that's good um but also then when it
comes in touch with data right um like
that quote everyone has a plan until
they get punched in the face so every
model is like perfect until it gets
punched in the face by your data set
and then you're like oh well i guess
this wasn't quite the case and then you
revise right and then you learn
something about the data maybe at the
end of the day you throw away the model
right because now you really understood
what it is and maybe it's something very
simple that you can do
but the path is what got you there
so then the second part of the question
um
goes about frequencies modeling which
she says is often faster
to run
because it's off the shelf so
um that is a little bit more nuanced i
understand the premise and i agree with
it to some extent that um
there is very much also this um
technique mentality right
um where instead of scikit-learn you
have stats models right so you import
your t-test or your ols and you run it
and it takes a couple of seconds and
then you get your output summary and
you're done so that seemingly is as
simple as machine learning
and in a way it is but there it's a
little bit more tricky because
um by using these off-the-shelf
statistical tests um you can shoot
yourself into the foot really easily so
for example maybe your data is normal
because you have outliers maybe it's
count data right in that case you
violated the assumptions of your test if
you haven't if you use a t-test for
example right which is normality
assumption
and then the results that you get
are
going to be biased so
or
maybe the algorithm hasn't even
converged correctly yet right you have
some like crazy complex model that's
overfitting like crazy but you actually
don't know um you still get answers but
it doesn't really tell you about the
quality of the answers so it's very easy
to think that you actually have a good
model while you actually don't
and
part of what makes bayes modeling hard
is that it's really shouting loudly at
you
when you do something wrong and that's
actually a great benefit
because that is what coupled with this
fog theorem right is
when your sample doesn't converge right
you know that you have a bad model most
of the time
so
and you want to know whether you have a
bad model right you don't want to fit a
bad model that doesn't fit well um
and and have a better sampler
it's telling you that you need to
improve your model and
that takes time
so
um
i guess one way
um
so yeah i would say
so that is usually what i say then
to stakeholders that frequent statistics
is more inflexible and gives biased
results
um
we see this for example with a b test
all the time right so people are like oh
i
have an a b test
um let me just run a simple t test well
first of all it's count data
second of all um what they often do is
like oh i ran the a b test
my experiment for a day
p-value is not below 0.05
two days still not below 0.05 and then
after a week like oh now it's below 0.05
perfect that's what i wanted so now i'm
going to go live with this version but
this repeated testing something that you
just cannot do and frequent statistics
right because frequent statistics is
very
backwards in this philosophy so it's not
wrong
but it's just
wrong for most of the questions that you
actually want answers to um so p values
are famously misunderstood
and
i can't even
explain here what a p-value is because
it just
is so weird um that most people would be
like just like what did you say
and
if you ask scientists for example what a
p-value is they describe to you what a
bayesian
probability is the bayesian
interpretation of it just because it's
so weird so by now the replication
crisis and all that are really good
indicators that frequent statistics is
just
not
does not provide the answers that we
usually want um and aspires in all these
different ways and this apparent
simplicity is i think um
sort of um a false
uh benefit because you actually don't
get the benefits you just get the speed
i hope thank you super useful thanks
glad that was useful
um
it is worth mentioning that the
frequentest and i'm i'm on your side of
the discussion but it is worth always
reminding that frequentest and beijing
approaches lead to the same answer when
n is very high
and then you really want bayesian when
you're dealing with smaller sample size
that plus the benefit of bayesian using
you can use priors
right so i think those are two arguments
that one should have in mind
yeah um
i'm not sure actually it has to be true
that with lots of data you get the same
answers um but
but nonetheless so the added flexibility
of business modeling i think that is
actually the best selling point is um
you can build models like hierarchical
models
um
the frequencies have that with mixed
effect models um
but there are also some critical
elements missing there so they have some
approximations
of the real thing um
a hierarchical model um but yeah it has
all kind of issues so the flexibility um
the fact that you get better uncertainty
quantification so this concept um of
uncertainty is just much more grounded
than frequent tests when you have this
weird sampling approach and
um
well there's one example right where you
have a confidence interval um but then
the confidence in the world is actually
out completely outside the domain of
what is even possible in terms of values
it's not even does not even include any
of the data points that you have
observed so they are like some
uh with cases and it's not that the
confidence interval is wrong right it's
just that we all understand it wrong
um
so yeah
yeah those are excellent points thanks
for that
yeah thank you
um
okay what else do we have
i often find so this is from chris i
often find creating a data generating
function creating by
toy examples difficult process you have
a new suggestion for getting better at
this or any plans to include in the
course
interesting um
so
yeah this is something that i haven't
really mentioned as much is
that these beta models are inherently
generative so often what you try to do
is
you have a generative process in your
head
and
you
map that to the model so you have that
generative process of how my data was
generated has some hidden causes
and i have an idea of how these hidden
causes give gave rise to the data that
are observed
so now that i and then i built a base
model to essentially map that generative
process right so that general process
has these hidden causes my parameters
and priors on them
and then through some other
distributions and some
computations
it
then generates the data and then of
course in reality i only observe the
data and then one reason backwards from
given that have observed this data what
are the most likely hidden causes that
have generated it
and that's what base and statistics is
doing and that's what base formula is
doing right it's just inverting this um
back in the day it also used to call it
be called inverse probability because of
this property
so
so i would even say that if you have
so the question is maybe um okay so i'm
going to interpret this in a particular
way um and maybe that's the wrong way
but
um i would
go as far as saying that if you don't
if you can't write down the general
process easily
you don't really understand your problem
well enough
so i think that's
what i would
invest in is in thinking more clearly of
like what is the almost like the
physical process that generated it right
so
one example that i like to use is that
um
[Music]
a covet reproduction model that we
worked on with um kevin systrom of all
people the founder of instagram
there was a website rt.live it's not
live anymore but
um
we worked on this model in pymc with him
and
this was like for me the epitome of
uh generative modeling
because uh you wanted to estimate
on a certain day what was the
reproduction rate the effective
reproduction rate meaning
one person infected two other people
three other people one other person 0.5
per people right so that was changing
all the time so that was the hidden
cause but for to go from that hidden
cause there's many things
until you actually observe the data and
the data being
that you that how many people got a
positive test on that day
so
in between you have well uh person a
affects
two other people and those two other
people first have an incubation period
then they have a certain probable
distribution of developing sentence and
then they have a certain delay until
they start actually get a test once they
have symptoms right and then
there's the testing frequency so can
they even get a test right because that
change over time
so all these things right so from the
one person infecting to another down to
um
then coming up in the final statistic
the data set that we have uh it's like a
long causal chain of individual steps
and there's like delays in there too
right so usually that number only gives
you about like the people that got
infected two weeks ago right so there's
this whole delay thing
and we mapped that whole process to pipe
c it wasn't easy um
but requires us to really like dig in
and think deeply about this and stand
the domain um
so
there's no shortcut to that i would say
um
but certainly the course that we have
will go through that whole logic and how
once you understand it how you how you
pour that into a model and how you map
that so that still requires domain
expertise or at least talking to the
domain expert to get their download
but once you have that the course will
tell you how to do that and
and one good exercise that we also often
go through is
to test is to just build the model
without any data and just generate data
and then you see okay does that generate
the types of patterns that i expect from
my data
it's called a prior predictive check
so i hope that that was
[Music]
useful and i understood your question
correctly chris
um sean law
um
oh yeah i know you're from twitter
um
is there a good resource reference that
you can recommend for seeing practical
examples for where pioneer generally
works best um
so actually i'm gonna
so there's a whole bunch here um this is
the time c website and then also with
code
and
then
um
yeah so there are certain case studies
actually on the um
and then here
in the slide deck i also have some
examples so this is the kobit 19 example
that i talked about
um
then
uh we have a blog post out on our
primacylabs.org about how we work with
with hellofresh on the market mix model
so this is a model where
you have all kinds of different
marketing channels
google ads facebook ads tv ads um
radio write everything and then you only
observe a single thing which is how many
customers have you acquired
and you want to know how much did each
channel contribute to this so you're
trying to re-map like un undo this
many-to-one mapping
and uh prime c is the model and like
that is used in production so this is a
very famous model um
but i agree that actually there's not a
whole bunch of good success stories so
by now we know um quite a few
um
of those but um
yeah not everything we have written up
yet so here's another slide deck also
with some examples
um and one i particularly like
civics for example we also worked with
them so they civics.com i think
they have a political sentiment so
how do people think about the coronal
virus outbreak so this is a bayesian
model also that's running production
every day and we help them speed it up
yeah so those are some examples but i
agree
there could be more
how compare stan and prime c doesn't
even make sense to compare them i mean
yeah they both try and do the same thing
so um
stan and pime c came out
roughly at the same time stan a little
bit earlier
and they were both the first ones to
work on
work with the nut sampler
which really changed the game
and
they
[Music]
and we actually copied a lot from stan
so a lot of the
um because they are not only the people
writing software but they're also often
the people like gelman really pushing
the field forward so
um we are indebted to them in many ways
uh because they gave us a lot of tips
and help earlier on on how to do this
and yeah a lot of things are just copied
from them
um they chose a little bit uh quite
different approach technically where
they said okay well we're gonna write
our own
c plus plus backend almost um
and we just decided to use theano and i
think that was good choice for us
um just because the simplicity so the
whole pymc codebase is much more
approachable much easily hackable
um
and now actually i think there's many
things that we can do with these whole
high-level symbolic rewrites right
because we have access to the whole
graph
um
of these computations like here's a
normal random variable and you multiply
that with another one so what happens
here and we can rewrite this so that
allows us to do many things they that
are really hard for them to do
um
so i think that's a good thing and then
also now we have the ability right to
switch out these computational backends
uh which is also going to be difficult
for them because they're sort of married
to c plus plus um
so i would say those are some of the
differences
um personally i think
uh my biased opinion as one of the
authors is that
the pimc model specification api is
nicer
i think also i think objective if that's
the case in stan you have
to have the
define like a random variable sometimes
in three places right one is for the
transform and then how you want to use
it
but they also have some really nice
features that we don't so loops for
example um you can write some time
series models much nicer in stan um
although in primacy 4.0 we will be able
to have the same way
of doing that so
um but yeah so stan is amazing um
and and they have a great community um
uh but yeah i would still say if you if
you actually are a python user um i hope
pymc gives you the better experience and
if not that's something that we want to
fix
100 data points yeah exactly so that's
where in dna
sequencing
um
no it wasn't sequencing it was dna yield
so i'm measuring the concentration based
on reagents
yeah
sequencing is a much more complicated
problem
yeah and that's where i have tons of
data too yeah
uh here's one raphael um
this is possible these empirical
distributions along with prime c
sometimes using something like
bootstrapping
approximating distribution is more
convenient than having a specific one
so
there is a thing
where you can approximate distribution
from samples
so basically histogram
and
that is even here somewhere um
i have too many even windows on top of
it let me see
um
well
i won't
i probably won't be able to find that in
time but there's an example here um
where you can do that um
and
if however i wouldn't recommend it
so
um
most likely there is a
better solution i would say and
if you tell me what your problem is i
think i would be able to recommend that
so
um
there's all often just a handful of
distributions that are relevant so when
you first come to business modeling
um it's like oh well there's like
hundreds of distributions which one
should i use in in reality there's like
four or five that are common like the
normal distribution student t
distribution beta distribution
um
negative binomial if you have count data
and then a half normal
um
i mean that's that's pretty much it um
so if your data is
um if you have a prior right then
um you probably don't have that much
information that you can approximate
some other ways if it's a likelihood
function
um
i would be surprised if it like looks
really weird and maybe if you have skew
right then things could be a little bit
more weird but then there's a skew
normal distribution
or there's transforms that you can do on
your data right so if you log transform
your data sometimes that makes it into a
normal you have outliers then use
student t
um so yeah i think
uh there are ways but i don't recommend
it and i think there's a better solution
cool i think this is most of them and
we're right on time
excellent uh well fielded for the
questions there thank you for scrolling
through
uh the chat and keeping on top of that
um
and thank you everyone for attending and
sharing so we have our next speaker in
three hours time that's tariq rasheed
talking on ai fairness and the state of
the art a very important topic um you
you've got the email that's got the
links for today and so go back to the
email for um tariq's zoom call uh in
three hours time and then on wednesday
we'll have uh myself uh speaking on a
higher performance python marco
bonzonini talking on natural language
processing
and some of the directors of num focus
talking on why you benefit from
contributing to open source
so please join us for the subsequent
talks wednesdays will be emailed out
shortly um and then for now if you can
thank thomas on twitter or linkedin and
follow up with those other links with
him um that'll be to your benefit all
right thank you very much everyone for
attending and we'll see you in the next
one
thank you thomas everybody had a great
time